er hat es nicht leicht gestern abend
draußen beim bürgerdialog in magdeburg
drinnen will der kanzler vor allem mit
entlastungen punkten wir senken die
mehrwertsteuer auf gas damit dass eine
entlastung für die bürger bürger gibt
und dann kommen noch andere sachen die
wir machen werden und die werden auch
dringend nötig sein denn ab oktober
sollen gaskunden eine umlage von 2,4
cent pro kilowattstunde zahlen die
gasrechnung spielt zusätzlich zum
gestiegenen gaspreis um viele hundert
euro im jahr an viele menschen bringt
das ans limit wird aber nicht nur gast
mache sondern auch lebensmittel und
schwung und man muss das ja alles
finanzieren können na und mit normalen
gehalt wie ich das jetzt verdiene ist
das teils schon nicht mehr möglich ich
habe noch ein holzofen zum glück
also cas bleibt es ja zu ziel der gas
umlage laut bundeswirtschaftsminister
insolvenz bedrohte gasimporteure wie das
düsseldorfer unternehmen juniper zu
unterstützen die jetzt wegen der
reduzierten gaslieferungen aus russland
an dass ruth euren ersatz beschaffen
müssen der unmut ist groß denn auch
krisengewinner greifen mit ab seite 34
milliarden könnten an unternehmen gehen
die in der krise milliarden gewinne
eingefahren haben das ist alle
verbraucher herangezogen werden alle
gaskunden damit verschiedene unternehmen
ihre profite hier nicht nur halten
sondern sogar steigern können ist das
einfach eine abzocke und die opposition
spricht von einer chaos umlage
handwerklich schlecht gemacht unsozial
und ungerecht die cdu will sie im
bundestag kippen trotz fehlender eigener
mehrheit ich höre auch aus den
regierungsfraktionen sehr viel unmut
über diese umlage dann muss man aber
dann jetzt auch farbe bekennen und vor
dem ersten zehn sich schnell wieder
abschaffen um ein scheitern der
gasanlage zu verhindern muss der
wirtschaftsminister nun schnell dafür
sorgen dass das geld auch sicher bei den
richtigen land
wir sehen aber natürlich auch wie viele
trittbrettfahrer ist jetzt gibt wir
prüfen noch einmal ob man auf
anfrage ist es mir wirklich nötig nicht
auch noch mal
eine regelung findet dies dem
unternehmen schwerer macht gestern abend
überraschte dann der
bundesfinanzminister im zdf das ziel der
gasanlage kann plötzlich ganz anders als
beim bundeswirtschaftsminister es geht
nicht darum irgendwelche konzerne zu
retten sondern es geht darum
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher zu
schützen die idee des
wirtschaftsministers war und sie ist im
kern richtig er beteilige ich mich nicht
an der pauschalkritik dass man sagt wir
machen eine solidarische lösung unter
den gasen hunden und gaskunden sie
sollen mit der umlage die
unterschiedlichen einkaufspreise der
gasunternehmen ausgleichen ob dieser
gedanke die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher tröstet ist mehr als
fraglich
also handwerklich schlecht gemacht wenn
es wird unter anderem nicht geprüft ob
ein unternehmen in wirtschaftlicher not
ist oder nicht es wird also nicht
geprägt geprüft ob eine insolvenz droht
und doch hat das kabinett die gasanlage
vor drei wochen auf den weg gebracht die
spd chefin macht da nicht mit sagte sie
gestern es müsse nachbesserungen geben
sonst blockade im bundestag und damit
guten morgen saskia esken
guten morgen frau wie würden sie denn
verhindern dass unternehmen die weiter
gewinne machen von der gas umlage
profitieren
da für mich ist relativ klar die
gasanlage ist ja eine maßnahme der
energiesicherung das heißt es geht darum
dass wir sicherstellen dass verbraucher
in verbraucher auch weiterhin beliefert
werden das eben der gasmarkt nicht
zusammenbricht das nicht große
importeure angesichts der
wirtschaftlichkeitslücke zwischen
weltmarktpreisen und verkaufspreisen
jetzt die grätsche machen und das
betrifft betrifft tatsächlich importeure
wie juniper und andere große konzerne
die in anderen sparten eine menge geld
verdienen gerade zb der erzeugung von
strom die sind eben nicht in gefahr die
grätsche zu machen ich gesagt habe und
deswegen sollten die auch nicht
profitieren ja aber die frage war ja
jetzt haben sie noch mal die sachlage
beschrieben die kennen wir aber die
frage war ja wie würden sie denn
verhindern dass genau die unternehmen
die immer noch profitieren nicht von der
gasanlage dann profitieren
ja jetzt wird die gasanlage ja von allen
gaskunden erhoben von th edi haben wir
damit beauftragt und am ende muss aber
würden müssen wirtschaftsprüfer muss
auch die bundesnetzagentur prüfen die
ansprüche der unternehmen bei der
auszahlung muss eben geklärt sein ist es
notwendig braucht das unternehmen diese
unterstützung um eben weiterhin auch die
versorgung sicherstellen das ist das
ziel der gasanlage nicht etwa der
sicherung von rendite aber unternehmen
können also nachweise liefern ob es eine
wirtschaftliche notlage besteht oder
nicht aber genau das verhindert das
gleichheitsgebot
dann muss die gasanlage so ausgestaltet
werden dass es funktioniert es darf
nicht sein dass weder mit mit mitteln
der der kunden oder kundinnen oder auch
mit steuermitteln unternehmen
unterstützt werden die diese
unterstützung nicht brauchen aber noch
mal nachgefragt wie also kritik ist ja
angekommen und die äußeren ja viele aber
wie kann man das jetzt machen
das ist liegt im ressort des
wirtschaftsministers wir sagen jetzt
seit einigen tagen ja schon er muss
genau hinschauen damit eben nachher bei
der auszahlung der mittel diese diese
gerechtigkeit auch gewartet und auch die
zielgenauigkeit gewartet die mittel die
wir den den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
dem fall den verbraucherinnen von
brauche verbrauchern abverlangen die
müssen auch ganz gezielt so eingesetzt
werden dass sie den dänen worum es geht
nämlich schutz der verbraucherinnen
verbraucher und sicherheit der
versorgung frau es gern wenn jetzt auch
aus dem kabinett einige nachbesserungen
fordern warum hat dieses kabinett unter
führung des spd-kanzlers dann diese
umlage eigentlich vor einem monat auf
den weg gebracht
im kabinett werden eckpunkte von solchen
verordnungen vorgestellt und dann wird
auch gemeinsam beschlossen dass dieser
weg zu gehen ist er ist ja auch angelegt
im energie sicherheitsgesetz und jetzt
kommt es eben auf die umsetzung an um
die auf die ausgestaltung das ist
angelegenheit des wirtschaftsministers
und wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass er
jetzt dort auch die notwendigen schritte
machen wird und doch ist es irgendwie
erstaunlich dass auch der finanzminister
lindner gestern sagte er kenne die
fakten gar nicht man hat so ein bisschen
das gefühl in der ampel weist der eine
nicht was der andere so richtig macht
und ein anderes beispiel erst die
belastung durch die gasanlage dann drei
tage später ein bisschen wie aus dem
zauberhut verkündet dann der kanzler
eine entlastung durch die mehrwertsteuer
sieht das eigentlich für sie nach einem
gesamtkonzept aus unter führung des
kanzlers
es war wichtig dass wir sicherstellen
dass nicht über die gasanlage und über
die höheren gaspreise der staat auch
noch profitiert indem mehrwertsteuer
geht ja in die kassen des des staates
und das darf nicht sein dass bürgerinnen
und bürger unter gestiegenen preisen
echten und wir profitieren sozusagen als
staat noch in diesem maße wie das jetzt
gewesen wäre bei der gasanlage deswegen
ist die reduzierung der mehrwertsteuer
an der stelle auch genau richtig die
gleicht aber natürlich auch nicht alles
aus jetzt sind sie chefin der
sozialdemokratischen partei haben sie
ein klares einfaches konzept wie
menschen die die
energiepreissteigerungen also nicht nur
die gasanlage nicht stemmen können ganz
gezielt entlastet werden könnten paket 3
soll ja bald ebenfalls irgendwann bald
kommen
wir haben schon in den ersten beiden
entlastungspaket das haben auch
verschiedene
wirtschaftsinstitute uns nachgewiesen
und bestätigt ganz gezielt menschen mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen in den
blick genommen und es ist auch wichtig
wir müssen denen helfen die eben sich
nicht selbst helfen können die über
keine rücklagen verfügen und für die
jetzt auch die drohen der heizkosten
nach zur zahlung einer existenzbedrohung
tatsächlich darstellt deswegen muss auch
im dritten entlastungspaket die ersten
beiden gingen ja auch schon über ein
volumen von 30 milliarden euro muss auch
genau diese bevölkerungsgruppe die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen die
rentner mit den kleinen renten die
familien mit den geringen einkommen die
müssen unsere zielgruppe sein das wird
uns auch gelingen da gibt es nicht die
eine maßnahme die gut funktioniert
sondern es wird ein bündel an maßnahmen
seien wir haben ja schon gehört dass das
wohngeld nicht nur ausgeweitet werden
soll einbezugs kreis sondern auch erhöht
dass das bürgergeld und einen höheren
regelsatz in der grundsicherung bedeuten
muss wir müssen für höhere löhne sorgen
das tun wir mit dem mindestlohn wir
müssen aber auch dafür sorgen dass von
den höheren löhnen tatsächlich bei den
menschen auch was ankommt dann sage ich
an dieser stelle danke für dieses
gespräch es ging um die gasanlage und
sicherlich sind alle darum bemüht dass
die gasanlage nicht ein über gewinn
bonus am ende sein wird saskia esken war
das partei chefin der spd alles gute
dankeschön